son courage est salué partout sur les
réseaux sociaux depuis hier face à la
série en syrien qui a blessé au couteau
au moins 6 personnes dont deux enfants
encore entre la vie et la mort à Annecy
Henry 24 ans a tenté de s'interposer à
plusieurs reprises dans une vidéo le
jeune homme chargé d'un sac de randonnée
sur le dos qui un tête à abdelmassi
Hanoun avant de le poursuivre pour
l'empêcher de pénétrer à nouveau dans le
parc pour enfants sur une autre vidéo
filmée par le passant l'homme dépose son
plus grand sac gardant le petit en guise
de protection pour mieux courir après la
Saillon diplômé en philosophie à
l'Institut philosophique catholique et
titulaire d'un master de management le
jeune homme fait le tour des cathédrales
de France à pied depuis la fin du mois
de mars il en rencontre via une page
Facebook une page Instagram et un compte
TikTok le héros sac à dos comme on
l'appelle s'est exprimé sur facebook
union de prière immédiate pour les
victimes de l'attentat d'Annecy a
d'abord publié le jeune homme en story
avant de préciser priez pour les enfants
moi je vais bien réagis instinctivement
pour moi c'était impensable de rester à
rien faire
selon ses publications sur les réseaux
sociaux il a entamé ce pèlerinage des
cathédrales à l'abbaye Sainte-Madeleine
du Barou près de Carpentras avant de
poursuivre à Avignon Arles Montpellier
Monaco et de remonter jusqu'à Annecy
j'ai toujours eu le goût de la marche et
l'associer au cathédrales c'est en
quelques sortes réalisées un grand
pèlerinage expliquait-il aux médias
catholique à l'étéia début avril
évoquant son voyage comme une démarche
personnelle et même spirituelle Henri va
aussi rencontrer Emmanuel Macron qui se
rend à Annecy ce vendredi
[Musique]